[Music]
thank you
in his essay on fairies stories J.R.R
Tolkien is going to talk about Escape as
one of the features or aspects of fairy
stories and indeed of a lot of narrative
literature as well he says that I have
claimed that escape is one of the main
functions of fairy stories and since I
do not disapprove of them it's plain
that I do not accept the tone of scorn
or pity with which Escape is now so
often used a tone for which the uses of
the word outside literary criticism give
no warrant at all and he's going to
engage in some interesting
Reflections on why we would actually
condemn something for being Escape he
points out
this is very ingenious that in what the
misusers are fond of calling real life
and we should actually pause on that for
a moment
so many people use this term and Tolkien
actually
capitalizes the r and the L as if they
know what they're talking about as if
they somehow have a lock on real life
that the rest of us just don't have you
see this with people say oh you don't
understand how business works you don't
understand how the game is played when
you have to deal with real life you will
act differently well how did we know
that they're in more in touch with real
life than we are and Tolkien says you
know if you think about real life
Escape is actually quite practical he
says evidently as a rule very practical
and it may even be heroic he says in
real life it is difficult to blame it
unless it fails in criticism though it
would seem to be the worst the better it
succeeds so you buy yourself some some
literature and you're reading it you're
engaging in Escape From the real world
that you should be constantly engaged
with you know if you and we could extend
this to all sorts of things you're
watching a television show oh it's not
60 minutes talking about problems you're
engaging in escapism and that's bad
right we could pick whatever other show
as if somehow 60 minutes isn't more
scripted and edited than other shows and
so he talks about this example of being
in a prison
if a person he says is brought into a
prison
why should a person be scorned if they
try to get out and go home to to escape
from the boundaries of the prison and
you could you know bring up extenuating
circumstance as well maybe they're
getting better Medical Care at three
Square meals a day I mean anybody who
knows anything about American prisons
knows that that's typically not the case
but that we could go on from there what
if they committed a horrendous crime and
they are you know convicted in their
heart not only by a jury of their crime
well okay that's not what Tolkien is
talking about he's talking about
somebody who's been put in prison and
has good reasons to get out and if they
can't get out he's got another very
interesting observation here he says if
Winnie cannot do so why should he be
scorned if he thinks and talks about
other topics then jailers and Prison
Walls the world outside has not become
less real because the prisoner cannot
see it so
you know there are people I've I've met
some within uh Indiana State Prison who
wanted everybody to focus just on what's
right in front of them the here and now
don't talk about anything outside and
the rest of the prisoners would be like
who the hell are you to tell me I can't
talk about anything else why would I
want to focus just on this stuff right
here there's a legitimate purpose to
escape or purpose is you could say from
tolkien's point of view and he says that
the critics are actually mixing up two
different things
so he tells us that we're faced by a
misuse of words and a confusion of
thought what is that he says that in
using Escape in this way the critics
have chosen the wrong word
what should they have chosen they are
confusing not only by sincere error The
Escape of the prisoner with the Flight
of the deserter so there's there's two
different pairings right Escape prisoner
flight deserter what is a deserter
somebody who should be staying and
fighting or doing their Duty and instead
they they leave they take off escape and
flight
are in some respects the same action
somebody is leaving somebody is hiding
somebody is subverting somebody is
taking off
but it's the action the motive of it the
way we would talk about the action
that's different the deserter is
deserting their duties The Prisoner who
is escaping is getting the hell out of a
place that sucks and that they don't
have a duty to stay in so the critics
often confuse these two things and he
goes on and he says that
just as a party spokesperson
might have labeled departure from the
misery of the fears or any other Reich
and even criticism of it as treachery in
the same way these critics to make
confusion worse and so to bring into
contempt their opponents stick their
label of score not only onto desertion
but on to other things
what are these other things that Tolkien
brings up he says they not only condemn
desertion which is the right thing to do
but also
real Escape
and where often its Companions and here
he brings up four things
disgust
anger
condemnation and Revolt a little bit
later he'll also talk about reaction as
well this is very interesting isn't it
because it's not just Escape that he's
saying you know you really there's a
legitimate purpose to it there is a
legitimate use of disgust there is a
legitimate use of anger there is a
legitimate use of condemnation there is
even a legitimate use of revolt and the
critics are blurring all of these things
together under one term that they call
Escape but which is really desertion
leaving behind what you have a duty to
confront or to work with and so he says
not only do they confound The Escape of
the prisoner with the Flight of the
deserter but they would seem to prefer
the acquiescence of the quiz laying to
the resistance of the Patriot to such
thinking you only have to say the land
you loved is doomed to excuse any
treachery indeed to glorify what was a
quizling well it was actually named
after a guy whose name was quizling and
he betrayed his country to the Nazis in
fact taking a position of power once the
Nazis had invaded his country of Norway
so
he's saying here that the critics really
have things backwards we shouldn't be
quizlings we should in fact try to
escape there's a legitimacy to this and
he's going to give us three interesting
examples which might be a little hard
for us to relate to and we might say
that's Tolkien is a bit of a you know
stick in the mud in in some ways but he
he talks about this for a trifling
instance not to mention electric street
lamps of mass-produced pattern in your
tail is escape you're not you're not
talking about the street lamps right the
way that you should and Tolkien says you
don't have to talk about Street lamps
right the lamps may be excluded from the
tail just because they're bad lamps and
it's possible one of the lessons to be
learned is the realization of this fact
and then he says but out comes the big
stick electric lamps have come to stay
they say and he says you know how do we
know that you you know maybe they're
going to be replaced by something else
down the line in 10 20 years as well
right he says the electric Street Lamp
May indeed be ignored simply because it
is so insignificant and transient and
fairy tales have many more permanent and
fundamental things to talk about
lightning for example The Escapist is
not so subservient to the whims of
evanescent fashion as are these
opponents he does not make things which
it may be quite rational to regard as
bad his Masters or his Gods by
worshiping them is inevitable even
inexorable right and here he actually
says maybe we'll pull down the street
lamps escapism might turn into reaction
then he talks about something else quite
interesting and look at listen to the
term robot factories right
in his time you know manufacturing was
increasingly including Automation and
people were having all sorts of you
could say wet dreams of Technology back
then and he talks about a clerk of
Oxford declaring that he welcomed the
proximity of mass production robot
factories and the Roar of
self-obstructive mechanical traffic why
because it brought his university into
contact with real life how often do we
hear things like oh those academics a
bunch of Ivory Tower egg ads totally
detached from real life not like us stem
people us technologists and you realize
when you spend much time with them that
they're often more deluded and less well
informed than the people who quite often
are somewhat deluded and ill-informed
and Academia as well and he goes on and
he says that
you know
in this case the expression real life
seems to fall short of academic
standards the idea that motor cars are
more alive than say centaurs or or
dragons is curious that they are more
real than horses as pathetically absurd
how real how stutteringly alive is a
factory chimney compared with an elm
tree poor obsolete thing insubstantial
dream of an Escapist he's pouring his
own scorn on them there and then finally
he talks about Bletchley stations roof
as another example he says I cannot
convince myself that the roof is more
real than the clouds and as an artifact
I find it less inspiring than the
legendary Dome of Heaven the bridge to
platform four is to me less interesting
than beef roast guarded by Heimdall with
the garage horn from the Wilderness of
my heart I cannot exclude the question
whether Railway Engineers if they'd been
brought up with more fantasy
might not have done better with all
their abundant means than they commonly
do
Mass fairy stories might be I guess
better masters of art than the academic
person I referred to so three
interesting examples
then the other thing that he says about
the legitimacy of escapism he says we
don't have to worry about archaism
he says if we leave aside a moment
fantasy I don't think that the reader or
maker of fairy stories need be ashamed
of The Escape of archaism of preferring
that dragons but horses castles sailing
ships bows and arrows not only elves but
Knights and Kings and Priests for it is
after all possible for a rational person
after reflection quite unconnected with
fairy's story or romance to arrive at
the condemnation implicit at least in
the mere Silence Of The Escapist
literature of progressive things like
factories or the machine guns and bombs
that appear to be their most natural and
inevitable dare we say inexorable
product so you know archaism and not
necessarily anything wrong with that
right and he says that many stories out
of the past have only become Escapist in
their appeal through surviving from a
time when men were as a rule delighted
with the work of their hands into our
time so you know that's something worth
considering he also briefly mentions
science fiction and he says something
really astute I think about its capacity
to be real Escape
he tells us that science fiction is that
most Escapist form of all literature but
then he says this
these prophets often foretell and many
seem to yearn for a world like one big
glass roofed railway station
but from them it is as a rule very hard
to gather what men in such a world town
will do what are they going to to do
what what will the Escape be he says
they'll use their freedom in order to
play with mechanical toys in the soon
cloying game of moving at high speed to
judge from some of these Tales they will
still be as lustful and vengeful and
greedy as ever and the ideals of these
uh their idealists hardly reach further
than the splendid notion of building
more towns of the same sort on other
planets and he he says this is an age of
improved means to deteriorated ends it
is part of the essential malady of such
days producing the desire to escape not
indeed from life
but from our present time and self-made
misery so this is a very interesting
point science fiction can be Escapist
but not provide real Escape in the way
that fantasy and fairy fairy stories
when they're working well do now of
course that's not to say that all
science fiction falls into that but some
science fiction winds up being
you could say on the one hand more
escapists than on the other hand less
Escapist in the sense that Tolkien is
saying is is a good thing for us so he's
making a case against the critics who
view escapism as a bad thing for it
actually being a good and perhaps even
necessary or heroic matter